les agents de la faune du
bas-saint-laurent haute une nouvelle
collègue depuis quelques mois c'est jay
lee berger allemand e
un berger allemand dit justement qui
vient de la grc des chiens policiers
sont déjà initié au travail de maître
chien jerry en fait un chien robuste un
chic et endurant c'est pour ceux qui
sont sélectionnés en fait pour justin au
travers d'un milieu forestier
évidemment genting travaille pas seule
elle est accompagnée de son maître chien
hubert chabot
ensemble ils accomplissent plus
efficacement certaines tâches notamment
celles liées au dépistage du braconnage
aux perquisitions ou à la recherche
d'individus perdu en forêt ouais vous
avez kodjo les nôtres sont bien
dissimulée dans le milieu naturel
c'est là que la chine va devenir ayant
des capacités olfactives développer il
va trouver ces éléments de preuve le
nécessaire à lenquête jetty et hubert
chabot ont suivi une formation intensive
de 15 semaines cette formation leur a
appris à travailler ensemble pour
détecter les odeurs aux jumelles collier
le chien ce que l'on recherche lodoli à
la chasse la pêche le piégeage cas qu'on
fait du tracking dépistage je me sens a
mené quelques actions ordinaires avec la
longue ligne que moi je couve en arrière
elle ce que le fou trouvé un individu
le maître chien se considère choyé
d'avoir téti comme coéquipière lefel
d'être constamment avec le chien de voir
le développement du chien de pouvoir
pousser l'entraînement je quelqu'un qui
aime entraîner comme ça avec le chien
est infini ses limites l'eau en 1996
l'escouade canine des agents de la faune
ne comptait qu'un seul maître chien ils
sont maintenant quatre à travailler à
travers le québec et même près de 300
interventions par année ici marie
christine riou radio-canada rimouski